now sticking with the labour leadership
theme we're now joined in the studio by
one of the five candidates who wants to
be labor's next deputy leader the shadow
justice secretary
richard bergen thank you very much
morning sir how are you being with us
i'm not too bad thank you
and i'm just interested first of all to
get your analysis
just heard from kirsten there about why
labour lost
the election and why you lost so badly i
think we had that devastating defeat for
a number of reasons but i think the main
reason was
that it ended up becoming the brexit
election
that boris johnson wanted and in many
parts of the country the issue of brexit
ended up overshadowing traditional
party loyalties i think that was a big
difference between 2017 where we nearly
won
in 2019 when we got smashed was that
brexit came into focus
overshadowed traditional party loyalties
i think the analysis shows that we lost
an equal number of votes to people who'd
voted remain
and equal and revert to people voted
leave but the disproportion
the distribution of those votes meant
that we lost over 50
parliamentary seats that voted leave in
the eu referendum it's interesting to
hear you
say quite clearly you think it was
brexit contrasting to kierstarma who
we've just heard from who
i put that to him as shadow brexit
secretary and he
said that he thought that the brexit
policy was the right one going into the
election promising the second referendum
and emphasized it wasn't just brexit
that lost that election could just have
a quick look at
what he told us he said people brought
up the leadership of the labour party
they brought up brexit they thought the
manifesto was overloaded
and in a number of places they brought
up anti-semitism so there are a number
of reasons do you agree with that from
kirsten well all of these things
have been mentioned but i think some of
them are linked for example
uh when keir says that they brought up
the leadership of the labour party
and the overloading of the manifesto i
think lots of these things came down to
trust
and so in 2017 we had the same leader
a manifesto of socialist policies and we
nearly won
2019 same leader manifesto of socialist
policies and we've got smash
and so do you think it's more about
brexit than kirsten was saying though
i respectfully disagreed on his analysis
in relation to brexit and i think brexit
did overshadow the election and so when
people didn't trust us to deliver the
policies in the manifesto
what people often say to me on the
doorstep is you couldn't even get brexit
done
and now you're promising this so i think
it went to the heart
of this and it's also why i think that
the people successful in portraying
jeremy not as an insurgent anymore but
more of an establishment
figure which is certainly not because
people have the idea that we were
somehow trying to block the will of the
people
in relation to our community the second
referendum was that a mistake
i think it was right that we tried to
bring um the country together but it
failed we got to be honest
about that that policy failed and any
idea
that by being clearly remain which i
think
keeps suggestions into i think he's
mistaken as well i think it would mean
even worse he would have tried that
many people in the labour party think
and kirsten reflects that a little bit
that the manifesto was a problem as well
but it wasn't credible
he wouldn't believe it do you accept
that no i don't accept that
i'm proud of the manifesto we stood on i
think the manifesto contains policies
which contain the solutions to
many of the problems faced by
communities and all that diversity
across the country and what i would say
is that the socialist policies
in the manifesto were not the reason we
lost the general election
it wasn't because of the 10 pound
minimum wage taking rail mail and water
into public ownership
that we lost the general election we
lost the general election because it
became
the brexit election some people listen
to that will say
you need to get real it was the worst
defeat for eight five years
of course the manifesto was part of it
always ideological purity coming up with
the right solutions
better than winning well i don't think
it's about ideological purity for
example our policy on taking the
railways back into public ownership
was supported by over 70 percent of the
public
of course and it was a devastating
defeat as you say
the worst general election result for
labour since the 1930s
but we can't throw out the baby with the
bathwater even in the aftermath of this
devastating defeat
we can't drop our socialist policies we
can't drop
our anti-austerity economics and so
that's why i'm clear
that whoever's elected leader of the
labour party they don't have
a mandate to ditch a single one of those
socialist policies
in the last two manifestos without the
express permission of labour members
every single policy in the last
manifesto should be kept
unless the members want to ditch those
policies yes do you think the country
really wants socialism you've just given
boris johnson an 80-seat majority
well when we ask the question as the
country wants socialism let's think
about what's the most popular
institution in our country
the national health service an example
of socialist principles put into
practice
where public good is put before the
pursuit of profits
and actually i think we should expand
those principles to other areas of the
economy other areas of society
as well and that's one of the reasons
i've made that clause for pledge about
public ownership and about opposition
to privatization which i don't know we
may want to later another
uh of your policies that's got a lot of
pick up is this peace pledge
uh now this is the idea that labour
shouldn't support military action
unless your party members explicitly
back it
so for example if you know a british
embassy abroad
was attacked as we've seen in iraq
recently with the u.s embassy
are you really saying that the
government shouldn't respond at all
until you've had the chance to ballot
hundreds of thousands of labour members
the policy has been
misrepresented firstly the policy of the
peace pledge says that members would
have their say
if the united nations aren't backing uh
the action
and if it's not the case that it's a
genuine national emergency
so if it's u.n backed if it's a genuine
national emergency
it wouldn't apply and we're not seeking
to change the british constitution
the prime minister's prerogative powers
would still apply and if mps still
really want to vote for war
because he thinks the best thing to do
or if that's what they do
then we can't stop them what this is
about is basically enshrining what
happened when it came to david cameron's
proposal to vote
to bomb syria in 2015 jeremy held
a ballot of labour members online over i
think a 48-hour period
over 70 percent of labour members voted
to say the opposed david cameron's
plan to bomb syria and members of
parliament labour members opponent
reflected upon that and in the end the
majority of labour mps
voted against supporting david cameron's
plan to bomb syria
if that happened in relation to syria
then i think that should happen
all the time apart from under the
exceptions that i've just outlined
at the same time though most of the time
when military action
is considered it is a national emergency
isn't it
iraq wasn't a national emergency our
intervention in libya wasn't a national
emergency
our intervention in afghanistan wasn't a
national emergency
for half of my uh life so for all of my
adult life
we've been involved in wars in the
middle east and i think it does shame
the labour party
that we were so associated with those
interventions
iraq was a disaster afghanistan was a
dilesta
libya was a disaster i think it's right
that labour members
should be allowed to have a say on what
the labour party's position is
the labour party is distinct from the
position of parliament or individual mps
if you or a labor government know which
is truly the aim shouldn't you be
representing
everybody not just labour members why
should it be labour members alone who
are going to decide policy like this
well it's parliament that would decide
whether a country goes to war or not
and the prime minister would still have
prerogative powers and mps
wouldn't have to vote in the way that
the party wants them to do
in all political parties mps sometimes
vote contrary to the wishes
of their mps and of course are a
political consequences to that for them
quite often all i'm saying is that never
again
should labour members have to protest
not in our name
against their own government as i did
when i protested against the
iraq war the reality is um
when we get away from the rest of it uh
some of the things have been said about
this uh policy
labour members should have the right to
express
their opinion on what the party's
position should be on the most serious
thing a political party can do either
supports military action
or oppose much action um quickly you
told half post this weekend um
that if jeremy corbyn was shadow foreign
secretary that
would be ideal so would you like the
contenders for the leadership to be
considering
giving him that job in their shadow
cabinets well i think if they become
leader they should
consider all the options i the point i
was making in the interview
is that jeremy corbyn's made a fantastic
contribution
to socialist politics in our country uh
he's made many gains in the labour party
he's made an anti-austerity party
a democratic members-led party
an anti-war internationalist party i
think he'd do a great job
as at the point i was making in the
interview is that it's not the end for
jeremy corbyn he's got a long political
career ahead of him should he wish
he's ten years younger nearly than
bernie sanders who also has a big
political career ahead of him so i'm
sure whatever jamie wants to do
he's got a big contribution to make it
to our party okay now
you are only one of only two candidates
to not sign up to ten pledges
uh put forward by the jewish board of
deputies saying they would like all the
candidates
to sign up to them now we can just see
them here on the wall i mean there's a
few of them
um what don't you agree with here
clause eight for example i mean just to
say i think it's very important we do
work with the board of deputies
to fight anti-semitism on a whole host
of other issues
in relation to the eighth pledge
that does concern me because it talks
about fringe jewish groups
and i want to work with groups right
across the jewish community
not just with the board of deputies so
for example the constituency mp
was seen as very strange if i were to
say i'm only going to work with this
kurdish community group but not that
kurdish community group i'm only going
to work with this
nigerian community group but not the
other night do you think you know better
then than the board of deputies on how
to deal with anti-semitism no no of
course not and that's why
it's important we work with the board of
deputies on fighting anti-semitism but
when it comes to this idea
as a non-jewish person i should be
signing up something which declares
other jewish groups
as fringe groups like the harada jewish
community are they a fringe group the
lgbt jewish community the socialist
engagement engaging with the main jewish
groups doesn't stop you talking with
others so does it
well some people don't want us to talk
with what they call fringe jewish groups
i'm not prepared to accept that question
ban you from
talking to other groups so are they
i think it's important we engage with
groups right across the jewish community
it doesn't mean we agree with everything
they say
but i think it is very important that
the board of deputies
is obviously a very important group we
need to listen to them
we need to work with them but we can't
work and listen exclusively to them we
need to work
and listen right across the jewish
community and that's one of the reasons
that i
wouldn't sign the template i mean most
of the pledges uh i
agree with also the outsourcing of the
disciplinary process
we need more detail on that i'm yet to
be aware of any organization that
successfully
outsourced their disciplinary process
in 2014 you said zionism
is the enemy of peace given that
given your concern with these pledges
are you not worried that some people
will think you're not committed
to tackling anti-semitism within the
labour party of course i'm committed to
tackling anti-semitism in the labor
party and wider
society one anti-semite in the labour
party is one
anti-teammate too many so why don't you
just
sign up to the pleasures why is it that
you've said these comments in the past
that has worried the jewish community
well i said i made those comments before
becoming an mp and i've
explained in detail i wouldn't use that
phrase now which is a crude
oversimplification because the phrase
zionist doesn't just mean
netanyahu and his government you know
i've met
at peace campaigners who wants like the
labor party does who want like i do
a two-state outcome uh who class
themselves as a zionist because they
believe in a state
of israel so it was a crude phrase i
used before i was an mp that i wouldn't
use
now but the reasons i haven't signed
the pledges you know i've made clear i
think it's important i'm open and
transparent
uh about that okay now just to
end we did this with uh some of the
other uh deputy leadership candidates we
had on the programme before as well i'd
like to end with a quick quick file just
get getting to know you who do you think
is the best leader
in the labour party's history i think
kihar is the best leader in the labor
party's districts he founded
our labour party he was an anti-or
internationalist a socialist
an anti-racist who did more for
working-class people jeremy corbyn or
tony blair
i think it's not about individuals the
whole labour movement's uh
delivered dream shadow cabinet job
shadow foreign secretary
favorite band iron maiden ever kissed a
tory
not that i'm aware of okay richard
burgin thank you very much for being on
the show today
thank you